العلاقات مع اسرائيل ومصر، لكن
ذلك لا يعني استغناء انقرة عن
الخارجية التركي مولود شاوش
اوغلو ان تركيا بدأت تطبيع
والرئيس الصيني يحضر ملفه ليذهب
الى الرياض. فكيف سيكون رد
في الحرس الثوري الايراني شهران
بورصافي لقتل مستشار الامن
العاملين في منزل ترامب في
بلوريدا قام بالابلاغ باماكن
ميجاوات. رئيسة مجلس النواب
الامريكي نانسي بيلوسي ترتبك على
مبادئها. بس. واين هي المبادئ يا
حفيد عثمان؟ خرج المئات من
الكهرباء بطاقة اجمالية تقدر
بحوالي ثلاثمائة وخمسة وسبعين
بحصة مياه المصب وتدشين التوربين
الثاني للسد وتبدأ بتوليد
سيزور الجزائر في الخامس
والعشرين من اغسطس الجاري لبحث
كييب. واعلن الجيش الروسي ان
قواته تصدت لهجمات اوكرانية على
في موسكو بينما يستعد الرئيس
الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون الذي
النووية خرجت عن السيطرة تماما.
لقد انتهاك كل مبدأ من مبادئ
محطة زابروتش النووية ليرد
الرئيس الاوكراني الزينسكي ان
والتطورات. ترامب يتعرض للخيانة.
معلومات جديدة تتحدث عن ان احد
الكارثة حيث ستحمل الرياح هذا
الاشعاع لمسافة الالاف من الكيلو
للطاقة النووية في اوروبا. تخيل
معي لعدد من الثواني هذا
بالنار. القنبلة التي يخشى
العالم تفجيرها محطة اكبر محطة
واظهرت الصور وفقا لرويترز تضرر
اجزاء من القاعدة. قال وزير
الصناعية التقطت قبل الهجوم على
قاعدة ساكا الجوية في نوفو في
اثيوبيا تعلن اكتمال التعبئة
الثالثة لسد النهضة دون اضرار
سليماني بعد ان صدرت مزاعم في
الساحة السياسية حول استئناف عضو
ايران بالثأر من مقتل قائد فيلق
القدس بالحرس الثوري قاسم
هذه الزيارة بالتزامن مع
التدريبات العسكرية المشتركة بين
كارثة نووية محتملة في المحطة قد
تحدث في وقت قريب. وهنا مدير
موسكو وبكين وذلك وفق تقرير
نشرته مجلة جون افريك من المتوقع
موجهة رسائل ذات دلالة الى
المغرب وفرنسا ومتطلعة للتقرب من
السعودية تخطط لاقامة حفل
استقبال يتشابه مع ذاك الذي منح
تاي بي للاستقلال بمساعدة الدول
الغربية امر محكوم عليه بالفشل.
السعودي في الوقت الذي تتراجع
فيه علاقات السعودية مع واشنطن.
مقترح الصين حول بلد واحد
بنظامين لترد بكين وتعلق ان سعي
له اهالي قطاع غزة. كوريا
الشمالية تظهر في اوكرانيا.
بالولايات المتحدة دعما لفلسطين
رفضا للتصعيد الاخير الذي تعرض
امتلاك ترامب صناديق فيها وثائق
سرية. وانصار ترامب يتهمون الاف
الجزائر وروسيا لاول فما المغزى
من زيارتك يا ماكرون؟ الاحداث
عدد من الملفات مع الرئيس
الجزائري عبدالمجيد تبون. تاتي
النشطاء والمواطنين في مظاهرات
حاشدة في نيويورك وتشيكاغو
دوريفكا في جزيرة القرم وصورا
اخرى في اليوم التالي للهجوم،
خطابها على المنبر. نشرت وكالة
رويترز صورا لشركة الاقمار
السلامة النووية. الجزائر ترسو
في موسكو. ابناء عبدالمجيد تبون
جنوبي اوكرانيا دعت مجموعة سبع
موسكو للانسحاب من وتسليمها الى
لا يلعبون. حيث تعمل الجزائر على
تعزيز تعاونها العسكري مع روسيا
عقود. اما البشر ستصيبهم الامراض
السرطانية الخبيثة والتشوهات
ستصيب الاجيال جيلا بعد جيل. وفي
خضم تطور الوضع في محطة النووية
الروسية. هنا ستصبح هذه الاراضي
غير قابلة للسكن او الزراعة لعدة
السيناريو المرعب اذا تم قصفها
وحدث تسرب اشعاعي. هنا ستكون
لاستقبال حافل للرئيس الصيني شي
جين بينغ حيث ذكرت الجارديان ان
الهواء بعد تعرضها لموقف محرج اذ
وجدت خطاب الرئيس بايدن بدلا عن
القومي السابق جون بولتون ووزير
الخارجية السابق مايك بومبيو.
مترات وسينتقل الى معظم الدول
اوروبا والكثير من الاراضي
فما الهدف من هذه الزيارة وماذا
يريد اصحاب العيون الضيقة من هل
السعودية الصين اكبر واهم حليف
تجاري وهي المشتري الاكبر للنفط
الوكالة الدولية للطاقة الذرية
رافييل جروسي محطة زابروتش
ستنتقم بكين لزيارة بيلوسي من
قلب المملكة ومن قبلة المسلمين
ان يشارك وفد جزائري رفيع في
المعرض العسكري للجيش الذي سيعقد
بي اي بزرع ادلة في منزله بهدف
الحاق الاذى بسمعته اتهمت امريكا
للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب وتعتبر المملكة العربية
بعدها حرب التراشقات حول قضية
خاشقجي ورفع انتاج النفط لتنتهي
الرياض. بعد ان استقبل ابن سلمان
العجوزة بايدن بكل سخرية لتشتعل
طريق بالونات تم ارسالها من قبل
كوريا الجنوبية ما تسبب بانتشار
في فما كل هذا الكرم الحاتمي يا
كم? وما هو الهدف من ذلك? مهلا
الفيروس واصابة شقيقها فلا تثير
غضبها. ولا تنسوا انها الوحيدة
اعلن زعيم كوريا الشمالية
اعترافه بجمهوريتي دونتسك
واللوجنسك الشعبيتين اليوم تظهر
انظمة صاروخية كورية من طراز
الى امواج تايوان الغاضبة التي
رفضت كتاب الصين الابيض وترفض
المعركة ويعود بايدن بخفي حنين.
وها هي اليوم السعودية تتحضر
التي تمتلك نسخة من مفاتيح كيم
النووية. رياح الصين ترسو في
المنافسة لصواريخ هايمورس
الامريكية في القتال انت متأكد?
مهلا مهلا. ما كل هذا البكاء
والنواح? هنا تظهر كيم لتهدد
وتم رفع الكثير من التقارير حول
وجود قوة عسكرية لكوريا الشمالية
وترعد. وهنا تصف انتقامها
بالانتقام المميت ضد كوريا
الجنوبية بعد اتهامها بالتسبب في
تفشي فيروس كورونا في بلادها عن
بها الرئيس الاوكراني؟ ترامب
يتعرض للخيانة وايران تأخذ
يظهر سلاح كوريا الشمالية في
اوكرانيا وماذا يريد الرئيس
المصريين بهذا التصريح. كوريا
الشمالية تدخل الحرب. بعد ان
وماكرون يتدخل. وتركيا بتطبيعها
مع اسرائيل فيما اثيوبيا تصدم
نعم. حيث تم نشر هذا الخبر في
موقع المتخصص بالشأن العسكري.
الصيني من السعودية وهذه هي
القنبلة التي يخشاها بوتين ويعبث
بثأرها من قاتل سليماني والجزائر
تحرك ملفها العسكري مع روسيا
لماذا يبكي هؤلاء؟ ولماذا شقيقة
الزعيم الكوري تهدد وتتوعد هنا
الجانب الامريكي